instead of saying analyze this
theoretical problem I said analyze your
toenails tell me how much arsenic and
gold you've got in your body all we
study at MIT is the natural world and
things we make out of it so everything
is reducible to practice everything can
be real if you put in the effort today
in the podcast we're talking about
ionizing radiation and nuclear
engineering how do you make these things
real and tangible matter is a form of
energy and once that clicked everything
seemed to make sense radioactive decay
nuclear reactions all these things I
remember that aha moment in this class
that I teach as a second year student
back in 2002 and it's those kind of
moments that made me want to stay in it
because I feel like wow I really know
this field now welcome to choc radio a
podcast about inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare the nuclear engineering
and ionizing radiation course at MIT
take students from understanding basic
physics to grappling with the core
concepts of Einstein's e equals
mc-squared in this episode we're going
to delve into how this is possible and
what it takes to make a class that's not
only hands-on but also capable of
evolving daily my guest is one of the
main people that makes this happen
professor Mike short this course is all
about radiation both it's its origins
and its uses so this is the first course
on it's intro to everything nuclear that
any student at MIT would take and a lot
of times for students it's their first
modern physics course the physics
courses that first year students take
are often things that we've known for
100 to 300 years and the field of
nuclear physics is still evolving we're
still using nuclear radiation spectra to
detect the presence of water on Mars or
the moon we're still confirming our
knowledge of which particles do and
don't exist in Y so this is also intro
to modern physics so nuclear science and
radiation in particular are emotionally
charged top
you know you you read on the internet
claims like cell phones cause cancer
things like that how are you preparing
students to debunk pseudoscience and to
really serve the public we actually
spend two weeks at the end of the class
looking at studies that are false or
have exaggerated claims and teaching
students what to look for so the first
11 weeks of the class we teach the
students the fundamentals of nuclear
science and then we turn to published
articles and blogs and other things in
the field and we debunk myths like cell
phones cause cancer due to ionizing
radiation cellphones don't emit ionizing
radiation we debunk myths like the
tiniest little bit of irradiation can
harm you when in truth we don't have the
data for that but a lot of a lot of
misinformation in radiation and nuclear
science is incorporated into culture
into our sort of collective
consciousness and even in what's called
the linear no-threshold model which says
every little bit of radiation does harm
we don't know that to be true or false
and it's a good thing we don't because
we would need to have exposed tens of
millions of people to low levels of
radiation in a controlled study which is
not something I think is ethically
correct to do it's also not ethically
correct to say that all radiation causes
harm because we don't know and I want
students to both recognize false science
in the field and recognize when we don't
know enough information to say something
confidently and be comfortable with that
lack of knowledge it means there's
something new to explore but it's if you
don't have something to conclude don't
draw a conclusion mm-hmm how does this
connect to the irradiated fruit party
that you have in the class what what is
that yeah the last day of class we often
have an irradiated fruit party where I
bring in fruit that could only be
brought into the US because it's
irradiated so there are many fruits that
are there are many different types of
produce including fruits that are
irradiated and it's the only known way
to kill all of the insect viral and
bacterial pathogens that can wreak havoc
on either people or on our crops an
interesting point of information Hawaii
and Puerto Rico
despite being part of the u.s. our
agriculturally distinct in areas and you
are not allowed to simply import produce
from those I had an Apple confiscated
from the airport Puerto Rico
what I learned that to be the case
however if you were radiate foods like
this is why we can get a lot of
pineapples from Costa Rica we've started
getting mangosteens in from Thailand
where I didn't know what that fruit was
until a few years ago and now you can
find them at H bar in Cambridge a lot of
this is because we can kill the pests
and it doesn't harm the food it doesn't
make the food radioactive but a lot of
us is to personalize the science so when
students eat food that they may or may
not known of been irradiated they taste
good they seem safe and it's one of
those things where once it's
personalized it's not as scary when you
learn the knowledge and then you see it
for yourselves it becomes a lot more
acceptable yeah learning through
experience is very powerful what does it
mean to you for students to develop
fluency in this field it's important to
be fluent in this field because a
cursory knowledge of radiation science
is not enough I'd say there are a lot of
self-proclaimed experts I'll call them
armchair PhDs who have learned a bit of
genuine knowledge but then extrapolate
it too far and that combined with all
the things we've heard in pop culture
unfortunately sometimes from celebrities
spouting falsehoods about radiation or
vaccines or other things that they don't
understand people listen to other people
and people listen to role models and
folks that they look up to but it's
important to be fluent and well grounded
in the fundamentals so that you can sort
out fact from fiction and I want every
student that leaves my class to be able
to recognize something that's incorrect
even if it's told to them by a celebrity
an expert a parent a friend anyone that
they know what the reality is and it
shouldn't depend on the source it comes
from they should be able to tell whether
it's real or not and verify if the
source is genuine mm-hmm and how do you
help students develop this fluency so it
starts off with the fundamentals of
radiation science so like any class we
teach all the fundamentals from
well-established theory but along the
way every week we have labs and personal
as
like for example the first day of class
I asked students to bring in their
toenail clippings and they usually say
that's disgusting what are we doing and
I said you'll see we're gonna put them
in the reactor and we irradiated air
toenail clippings and because to some
degree you are what you eat some of the
elements which we eat and we don't want
to things like arsenic or selenium or
chromium some of which can be good in
small amounts that and large amounts
others like arsenic I'm not sure if
there's a good use of it get
incorporated into our toenails so we
activate those toenails by putting them
in the reactor they absorb neutrons and
give off characteristic gamma rays
giving away how many atoms of arsenic
and selenium and such are incorporated
into the toenails with striking
precision and so we're able to tell
where students come from based on
analysis of their toenails we had one
student who had a lot of gold in their
toenails and I said I thought I asked
you guys to you know clean these off
remove any polish and the student said
yeah I did but I live near a gold mining
town and it's in the water wow that's so
interesting so that's what I mean by
personal is they discover things about
themselves through nuclear science and
the problem sets instead of saying
analyze this theoretical problem I said
analyze your toenails tell me how much
arsenic and gold you've got in your body
right right so in the course you make a
point of saying that the method of
instruction is often context first
Theory second and then context again how
does that relate to that method of
instruction this is an example of that
method of instruction I like to start by
opening knowledge gaps rather than
spouting theory at someone it doesn't
usually stick if I just say here are
some facts learn them it's usually in
one ear out the other if they're
listening at all but when you show
someone something surprising they're
fully engaged they're all this
multi-sensory engaged they're they're
listening in a lot of cases they're
touching in some cases even smelling
taste is the sense that we don't tend to
engage in nuclear science with good
reason but you can sense and feel and
hear a lot of things in nuclear science
like yesterday I was you know with one
of my graduate students we were looking
at some highly irradiated materials of a
reactor and
Idaho and we heard this little faint
buzzing noise in the Geiger counter and
if you put your ear up to the Geiger
counter near the radiation source you
can hear tiny electrical discharges so
you could hear the detector working and
then I want the student to say why is
that why does why do I hear this fuzzy
noise near the detector when it's
working then when you explain why
students tend to remember mm-hmm not too
many people learn well by being lectured
at but everyone learns well by opening
knowledge gaps and you're effectively
pulling the information in rather than
us pushing it to the students something
I learned from a mentor here is you
can't push a string you want knowledge
into a student's brain they've got to
pull it you can't push it you made a
choice in this iteration of the course
to offer students the ability to do
analytical homework or take home
hands-on labs how did that work out what
did that look like in practice
interestingly I spent all this time
making these optional labs
nobody did them so the next couple of
years I simply made everything mandatory
the students said they love the
flexibility they're really psyched that
I put in all this time to do the labs
but it wasn't for a grade so they didn't
do it and so that's what I learned if
it's not graded it's not gonna get done
so I made all the labs mandatory cut out
a little bit of the analytics in favor
of adding context before and after the
theory and retention went up grades went
up on average and the course evaluations
went up too
so anything numerical we can get
improved and in my subjective opinion so
did the students knowledge of what's
happening and that I get from my
colleagues because I track these
students as they progress through MIT
through our department and my colleagues
who teach further on courses the more
advanced ones can tell me whether or not
the students really know the
fundamentals that they're depending on
so far things have been getting better
that it requires planning and it also
requires a lot of thinking where I'll
look through my syllabus and I have an
empty column where the user doesn't
exist in most syllabi which is what is
this week's hands-on instruction and I
try to make sure that's full so another
example is if you want to know do you
have real diamond rings when we get to
reading electron spectra and carat
mystic x-ray spectra I could either give
them a problem from theory which is
boring or I can run some standard for
them where you they know what to expect
or I can say that's a nice diamond ring
you want to know if it's real and the
student unbearably says absolutely I
want to know if it's real so we have the
student take the controls of the
electron microscope and analyze it to
see does that diamond emit zirconium
x-rays because if it is it's cubic
zirconia if it emits silicon x-rays it's
moissanite or silicon carbide my
favorite one was this day happened to
fall on parents weekend so I asked the
students does anybody have a diamond
ring and one of the students mother said
oh yeah let's check my engagement ring
and her husband was just oh god what's
gonna happen what's gonna happen he
thinks he bought a genuine ring turned
out to be real okay
we had the mic can you tell us about the
radioactive scavenger hunt sure I
challenged the students to find the most
radioactive place in Boston and each of
them had to go in teams of two and pick
a place that they thought would be
radioactive based on what we've learned
about where you find radiation so
radiation a lot of it comes from space
from cosmic protons that hit the
atmosphere so some students thought I'll
go to the top of the tallest building
and I'll probably get more radiation
others had read about radon underground
because there are isotopes of radium and
meeting radon gas and so they thought
we'll go down into the subway get as low
as we can go other students looked at
the relative amount of radiation and
different building materials like wood
clay marble granite and they went to the
most granite dense locations they could
find or the ones with the most marble
and those are the students that won
there were places in Boston that have
six times the normal radiation
background simply because they're made
out of marble or granite these include
things like the state house and some
fancy fountains around town did not know
about the fountains but they just
thought let's find giant chunks of stone
and they were right
[Music]
the hands-on experiences that might
creates for students of his course are
pretty unique he told me that when he
took this course as an undergraduate
student at MIT
it wasn't typically hands-on so I wanted
to know what it's like to teach in a way
that's so different from his own
personal experience what does it take to
create such fascinating labs and lessons
without a clear model from one's own
educational background its natural I
teach the way that I learn because I
thought back on all my experiences and I
thought from which courses did I really
remember a lot and these were things
like hands-on blacksmithing or
laboratory courses we did have a lab
class where we counted a lot of
radiation and I remember those labs very
well and then I think back to my
neutronics problem sets
I remember the theory okay but I don't
remember very many visual instances of
that class it just kind of happened my
knowledge just may be in there somewhere
I don't know but I know where I was when
I did most of the hands-on exercises and
in the end you can make anything
hands-on even neutronics that I
mentioned so I what some point went
skulking around places I oughtn't like
around in the reactor once I got access
and found an 8-foot pile of graphite
that was behind a bunch of equipment it
wasn't hidden it was just covered with
junk and I asked what's that they just
said oh that's our subcritical graphite
reactor pile you know we're gonna get
rid of that next year so I sounded the
alarm and said it cannot get rid of this
graphite pile and then our neutronics
professor's been forging cored Smith
said yeah you're right we can't so they
spent a whole winter restoring it with a
couple of students and now it's one of
the central labs in my class and in
their class so we've taken the most
Theory heavy dry and boring class and
turned it experimental because you can
you're only studying the natural world
right all we study at MIT is the natural
world and things we make out of it so
everything is reducible to practice
everything can be real if you put in the
ever
part of what's so special about this
class is the dedication that Mike and
his colleagues have to constantly
improving it through real-time student
feedback and I don't mean fixing pieces
to implement for the next semester I'm
talking about next-day transformations
of class procedures to accomplish this
Mike created the aptly titled rants page
the rant page is an anonymous simple PHP
comment form that I wrote where I want
students to tell me things that they
want changed because I I try my best to
collect in-person feedback from the
students most want both one-on-one and
in-class but some students don't feel
comfortable telling a professor I don't
like what you're doing so I give them a
place to do so completely anonymously
they could ended up being twenty lines
of code wasn't hard and what I started
getting was real-time feedback about I
can't read your writing so then I know
to slow it down or I really wish you
wouldn't slow the class down for this
one students incessant questions so I
know to limit each student to a few
questions if it gets to be too much and
I would address them in class to say
it's safe to address this because it's
anonymous I have literally no way of
knowing but if one person wrote it
probably a lot of you are thinking it
and the students responded positively to
say wow it was really nice to know that
we'd make a suggestion at 2:00 in the
morning and then by 10:00 in the morning
it would be addressed the class would
change in real-time and they knew they
had the power to shape their own
learning
[Music]
with all the buzz around this course we
had a ton of great questions come in
from educators and students alike so we
picked out some of our favorites and
posed them to Mike number one what math
do I need to understand this field
that's a good question
depends on how deeply you want to
understand the field if you want to pass
my class if you want to get an A in my
class you don't really need much math
beyond single variable calculus and even
then it's not very much I think we use
we have one or two lectures with
integrals and a few lectures with
differential equations but linear
first-order things that you solve in
calculus one number two when you were a
student how did you deal with courses
that didn't seem interesting to you but
that you had to study that's a good
question I have a few answers to that so
for courses that didn't seem interesting
that I had to study if I knew why I had
to study it there was at least a
practical reason to to do well for
example from you it was neutronics
Neutron transport is one of the things
that makes nuclear engineers what they
are I found it to be dry and not very
real-world because I knew I was never
going to be a reactor designer but I
felt I would need to understand Neutron
transport and power levels in order to
be an effective nuclear material
scientist luckily I was right for the
classes which I just had to take because
they were requirements and I had no
reason to want to take them I got a
little sneaky I ended up double majoring
with material science and wrote a
petition to get out of this one medical
imaging class and replace it with 12
others in order to make a second major
and that petition was approved so I
actually did get to simply drop a
departmental requirement by articulating
why I wanted to study something else and
not all students realize that they can
do this but they can do this with a very
good intellectual justification rules
can be bent or broken okay number three
why can't we just send nuclear waste to
space we could just send nuclear waste
to space and get it out of
our hair it would be expensive it costs
a lot of money per gram to get something
off the planet
someone has to agree to pay for it and
what worries me most is what if one of
those missions goes wrong what if you're
launching a rocket full of the world's
worst nuclear waste and something goes
wrong at the launch and then it comes
back down along with a rocket explosion
then you have contaminated the planet so
I personally believe in containing
nuclear waste where we can see it rather
than blasting it off into space and
contaminating space unless we know where
it's going and that nothing will go
wrong as a lot of folks are worried
about the dangers of radiation how are
we gonna deal with nuclear waste and I
don't fear nuclear waste but I've got a
healthy respect for it and that whatever
we do with it has to have the lowest
probability of getting out and
contaminating anything I think is a
necessary thing to make in order to make
nuclear power so if we want to make
almost unlimited carbon free power we're
going to make waste in the process
you can't fight thermodynamics you're
always going to have some waste of
energy or something else but then what
you do with it has to be very carefully
considered and it sounds simple to blast
it into space but then you have to think
what could go wrong and who could I hurt
if it goes wrong number four what do you
think about the cultural and political
idea against nuclear power to me the
current cultural and political idea
against nuclear power is not grounded in
fact it's grounded in emotion and I've
talked with a lot of folks who either
know very little or very much about the
physics and engineering of nuclear power
but I find more often than not it's an
issue designed to rally a base strangely
I've never really understood this so
many environmentalists are against
nuclear power and I'm an
environmentalist - which is why I'm for
nuclear power so I find the anti-nuclear
sentiment to be so strongly democratic
and the pro-nuclear sentiment to be so
strongly Republican neither of which is
for reasons which I'm willing to accept
they seem to be more about political
tribalism than fact
and it's interesting now that for the
first time since we've had Chernobyl
disasters and such more and more
environmentalists are coming out in
favor of nuclear power not because
they're in favor of radiation and waste
and such but the goal is to prevent
climate change I would much sooner take
a risk of something going wrong with
nuclear power then definitely lose the
battle to climate change everything to
me comes out to minimizing risk to human
life and maximizing quality of life so
to me the risk of nuclear power is that
if we can go all carbon free for energy
we can reverse climate change if we
refrain of using nuclear power for fear
of the wastes getting out or the risk or
the weapons then we're automatically
losing the war and we're going to have
an uninhabitable planet anyway and we
can't get off this planet yet and then
we'll go like then the same mistakes
there's a good here for example I came
into this department wanting to study
fusion felt it wasn't ready yet so I
spent a lot of my time on fission
thinking this is going to be the bridge
to fusion because fusion promises more
carbon free power with far less
radioactive voice but not none and I'm
willing to accept the sum so it's not to
lose the climate change battle which is
already at our doorstep I do worry that
many environmentalists lose sight of the
real goal which is protecting the planet
and to me protecting the plane that
doesn't mean do no harm it means do as
little harm as possible while preserving
our quality of life
number five while learning occasionally
you'll have these moments where all of
the sudden that dot suddenly connect and
a previously challenging topic becomes
seemingly perfectly clear to you could
you share with us one of your brain
blasts let's see for me it's the same
one that most students get at about the
one month mark in my class and that's
energy is matter that equals mc-squared
you see it on shirts all over MIT it's
probably the one equation that everyone
in America knows but not a lot of people
really understand it that the conversion
of
into energy through ionizing radiation
is the movement of energy from one form
to another
matter is a form of energy and once that
clicked everything seemed to make sense
radioactive decay nuclear reactions all
these things I remember that aha moment
in this class that I teach as a
second-year student back in 2002 and
it's those kind of moments that maybe
want to stay in it today I feel like
well I really know this field now if
you're interested in learning more about
ionizing radiation we've got all of
Mike's course materials on our site you
can find us at ocw.mit.edu
[Music]
in his OCW course page made especially
for educators you can find all sorts of
different instructor insights on our
educator portal at ocw.mit.edu slash
educator until next time I'm Sarah
Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare